[Music]
live from the PODS moving and storage
Studio this is the Ramsay show where we
help you win in your life specifically
your money life your work life and your
relationship life I'm Ken Coleman joined
by my colleague Rachel Cruz and we're
here for you this hour it is your show
America so what are your questions what
do you got we always love having that
conversation with you it's a free phone
call AAA
825-5225-88-825-5225 Rachel you ready to
go absolutely fantastic on this summer
day cheers there it is so there we go
we've never done this before there it is
you'll see a lot of that on the smart
money Happy Hour podcast with George
Campbell our colleague a lot of Cheers
going on Cheers
good I wonder what do I got to say to
James Childs our fearless producer to
have a little bit of that come on over
here I don't know we'll have to talk
about that on many commercial breaks but
let's get going Monifah is up first in
Washington DC Monifah how can we help
hi thanks for taking my call Ken and
Rachel so um my question is I recently
um purchased a new car
um because my car died on me I hadn't I
wasn't expecting to buy one for at least
another two to three years and um so now
I have um a bit of debt and my question
is uh do I have the option of paying
that debt off using stocks but um right
now the market isn't doing that well and
so uh I would
I would be taking not a loss but I would
kind of break even and I was just
wondering if I should
sell the stocks to pay that oh the other
thing um is I earned dividends on that
stock monthly so I get about 200 a month
off of that and I'm not sure if I should
sell the stocks or if I should just
pay it off
um by adding like extra payments to the
principal yeah for sure so uh how much
do you owe on the car
24. okay and if you sold it today how
much could you sell it for
uh I I'm not sure okay I mean it's it's
it's new I don't think that
um I kind of I looked that up and um
what I saw across the board was to like
hold off for a year because
um I bought it brand new so
I think it would depreciate too much as
in that first year to making money or
selling it well you may yeah you
probably are yeah you're probably not
it's probably worth less than 24. I'm
just figuring out what big of a
difference it is how much do you make a
year what's your what's your income
um it's 103. okay what other debt do you
have
um that's it
okay I mean honestly with your you have
a great income
um I mean if I were you I would just
buckle down and pay it off you could I
mean we always say to to cash out any
non-retirement funds that you have so
how much in stocks do you have
um the ones uh well the one that I would
that I could sell because it's up a
little bit would be there's 31 000 in
that one
um the others are down I don't know how
much are in there how much are in those
though
oh
um the second one has about 7 000 in it
okay 38. so 38 total is what you have in
stock and are those two single stocks
yeah okay so if I were you and and again
you haven't quote unquote lost anything
yes you may the return you're gonna
break even because yeah like you're
saying about the market but you
technically have not lost anything so if
I were you I would cash both of these
out I would pay off the car and then I
would put the remaining money uh and
again there may be some tax implications
to this but I would take the rest and
either use that cash to fund if you have
um do you have an emergency fund do you
just have cash on hand
um I I have an emergency fund but it
only has 2 000 in it okay so I would
cash out this and I'd pay it off and put
the rest in an emergency fund and I
would put the rest in that 2000 and then
from there money if I would never buy
single stocks again I if you have a Roth
IRA 401K that's going to be your next
step is to fund 15 of your income into
those things uh but I regardless of debt
or not I wouldn't have single stocks
anyway so I would tell you to cash them
out regardless of where you were but now
you're gonna have that lump sum and you
can use that to your benefit to just pay
off this car
and then turn around and fund an
emergency fund and then you'll be I mean
really in a great spot in baby steps
four through six uh at the point of what
we teach so that's what I would do if I
were if I woke up in your shoes
okay do it okay anifa it's gonna feel so
much better it is the single stock game
honestly it's it's exhausting and
majority of people don't come out ahead
now we tell people if you have
everything paid off if you're on baby
step seven and less than 10 of your net
worth you want to dabble in other stuff
like that's great but where you are
money for this is like really great
money to be used to get you out of debt
to have cash in the bank in case
something happens it just puts you in a
really great solid Financial spot to
build that strong Foundation financially
I totally agree that's what I would do I
totally agree and you're not worried
about the roller coaster anymore with
the single stocks you get into a good
investment strategy and I would
recommend money that you go to our
website ramseysolutions.com and we've
got a section there uh it's called smart
investor Pro now these are men and women
that are trained financial advisors they
will teach you the process for investing
that we endorse in the that we teach and
you're going to have a much better
feeling about your investment going
forward but this is an opportunity for
you to to cut your losses as they are
but the real benefit as Rachel said Is
You Come Away with this with a paid for
car and now you're on your way to baby
step three to get that emergency fund in
a place where you really sleeping well
and driving well so that's right this is
a no-brainer and you do walk away with a
different
picture when you go from having this
massive car payment Rachel to no car
payment at all and now this depreciating
asset
doesn't cause you any stress that's
right absolutely and because of your
income and where you're at financially I
think you can keep the car for some
people we'd sell you know if you were
making 50 Grands I would be telling you
to sell it and to take out a loan for
the loss
um of what you have but you're at a
position yeah I think you can still keep
the scar and pay it off and man I would
do that in a heartbeat yeah the uh does
it shock you when you see things on Tick
Tock and Instagram and social media
about people bragging about the car
payments like it's just a part of it
they're like yes have you seen these
videos oh my gosh they got a big smile
on their face like we owe 2100 every
month together as a couple yes I'm like
I'm choking watching the video it is
shocking and you do talk to people
what's funny is other people in this
space in personal finance that's out
there even like them you know if you
take 10 of us that teach this stuff you
know we all may disagree on probably
four or five topics right some people
are okay with single stocks some people
are okay with not having your accounts
combined when you're married some people
are great with credit card like we all
have our differences but one consistent
thing I do find Ken almost everyone
hates a car loan and the financial
advisor space because because they see
that there's no return on it's a
depreciating asset and you're putting
money in that where if you had invested
that so anyone Under the Sun even if we
disagree on the little things here or
there majority of people out there you
guys that are teaching about money they
all are like oh the car payment so and
nobody cares consistent nobody cares
about the car oh unless you walk around
going I just got the brand new whatever
that is nobody cares by the way that
makes you come across as a jerk that's
right we don't want to be that come on
people nobody cares just pull around the
corner park behind the building nobody's
here that's where you go aside all right
hey we gotta step away for just a few
moments don't move more of the Ramsey
show coming up
foreign
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
welcome back America you have joined the
conversation about your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships all three of those
topics are just completely woven
together and we want to help you win in
all three of those areas I'm Ken Coleman
I'm joined by my colleague Rachel Cruz
and I'm sure that no matter where you
consume your news
how much you consume your news
you're constantly hearing about
inflation
and interest rates that I can assure you
it doesn't matter who you are where you
lean one way you're in the conversation
for a while after 10 years now that's
right 18 months that's right so uh I
just want to give a snapshot to our
audience we have a lot of new people
joining us all the time we're so excited
that you're with us so how do the
interest rates as the FED raises or
lowers in this case we've been on a a
pretty steady uh path of raising
interest rates how does that affect you
day in and day out with your money so
for the past 14 months here's where we
stand uh interest rates have been
raising at the fastest clip Rachel in 40
years okay so this is a big deal because
we had a prolonged period prior to covet
where interest rates were at historic
lows okay and so now all of a sudden
pretty big jump now the FED just
announced last week
that they're going to hold the current
rate steady now this is the first time
Rachel since January of 2022 when the
FED has met and didn't raise it right so
they said or we're going to hold and
we're going to assess how are the
current rates affecting
the overheated economy that's the way
they describe it and that is all about
inflation anytime the FED addresses
inflation they're going to look at a
tactic of raising rates I'll get into
that why and how it affects us so uh
when they raise the FED fund rate the
rate that Banks charge each other for
their overnight loans
that begins to Ripple across the economy
where we see mortgages go up credit card
interest rates home equity lines of
credit and auto loans and then any other
type of loan that maybe you're dealing
with or that you can imagine that's
where you start to see higher cost
because the interest rate all right now
what that does is that affects you the
consumer because all of a sudden that
bill is more and then that changes what
you have to spend that given month that
it changes your budget if you're
budgeting and we want you budgeting and
so you start to feel what you you see
economists refer to as a pinch right and
so what happens well that means consumer
Behavior as it relates to purchasing
starts to slow down or at least the FED
hopes so they hope that consumers start
spending less because when consumers
spend more that's the whole Supply
demand that you learn sometime around
the sixth or seventh grade hopefully
that's right yep prices go up more
demand people raise prices well
here's where we stand
right now over the last 14 months
consumer Behavior didn't slow right away
we are seeing it start to dip a little
bit but when the feds first started
raising rates Rachel there wasn't much
change at all yeah then Jerome Powell
who's our Fed chair came out and said we
need to see some pain in this economy to
get control of inflation what does he
mean he meant specifically unemployment
going up he was and I I went after him
on my show I've gone after him on this
show uh it's the one time I've ever
agreed
with the Democrats uh in the Senate and
and they're saying look this is going to
take us into an unnecessary recession
that was my concern as well so all of a
sudden we've got Democrats going we
don't want to drive up unemployment why
because unemployment's low all right
back to how this affects groceries and
everything else when unemployment is
really really low
you get into wage Wars it's a war for
talent and we saw this where you go into
restaurants you're still going to
restaurants Rachel where they don't have
enough help yep so what do they do they
have to raise hourly wages they raise
salaries companies do to attract people
to have them yes work for them so then
created a great resignation and so the
cost gets wage pressures get passed on
to us the consumer the food when you
open the menu and it's going to get
expensive and it's more expensive it's
because they're having to pay their
people more groceries are more yep
because they have to pay people that are
stocking the groceries more yeah okay
and so all of this then begins to affect
our wallet now here's where we stand
inflation is dipping a little bit okay
but still prices are very very elevated
the job economy is strong in other words
the latest job report in may we saw a
slight tick up in unemployment but we're
talking to 3.7 percent not what they
were expecting not what the Fed was he
wants to say yeah he wants to see it in
the fives that's because it creates well
his theory is it's not always it doesn't
always work yeah raising interest rates
doesn't always work to cool the economy
and you could say right now it hasn't
cooled them because people are still
spending money like crazy I'm like you
travel you go into an airport and it's
packed you go you go to these places
you're like oh my gosh people they're
out they're they're doing stuff and yeah
it's the classic effect that DC does not
control our Behavior so us putting any
level of Hope in them like they're
trying to put hope in us that they're
like okay we'll try to control the
consumer's Behavior it's not as married
as what it appears to be or what people
think it is or what they think it is
yeah so where do we stand well inflation
hasn't dipped enough and the FED has
said they're going to continue to push
up rates and will it will it respond as
in we'll see unemployment Spike and make
calls come down I don't know and make
that connection again right that no make
that for the listeners like that
unemployment goes up oh well see one
unemployment goes up so what happens and
how that's tied to inflation so when
unemployment goes up people don't spend
as much because they're out of work yep
and so you it's a way of cooling
consumer spending businesses are letting
go people they are because they're
cutting costs because of inflation like
I'm trying to make the whole like no
it's just more expensive to do business
that's right so two things happen
businesses if the cost of doing business
is more and if you get interest rates
into a uh if interest rates drive you
into a recession that means the balance
sheets are worse companies aren't making
as much money so what do they do cut
cost their number one costs are
employees so what happens is they're not
producing as much consumers are getting
laid off they aren't spending as much
and so what happens is demand drops and
when demand drops
prices drop that's right like for
instance you know what would be fun it
would be fun if we could create a
national movement for 90 days
where where Millions upon millions of
American people
reduce spending dramatically not because
they had to but to lower inflation I
think we all do it together like let's
band together and attack inflation
together no no so there's going to be
some critics to this video they're gonna
go Ken you're heartless because that's
going to put people out of work
and presumably it would
but it is Supply demand it is capitalism
and then here come the people that think
oh capitalism capitalism is awful well
whether you think it's awful or not
we're not taking that position today
we're just simply explaining how this
affects your pocketbook yes and when the
red when the FED continues to raise
rates
it is going to hit you in your
pocketbook one way or another you're
gonna feel it in the grocery store goods
and services that you pay for and then
you could lose your job yes if
unemployment goes up because of a
recession right because businesses will
start laying off and what's fascinating
is uh I feel this can I wonder if you do
too but even when we are doing our
Building Wealth events around the
country 12 months ago like right you
said all the started 14 months ago man
that was the hottest topic because we
were talking about groceries the price
of stuff you know all of it and we're
all still feeling it but isn't it weird
that just like human behavior you get
used to something after a year
our budget has now cons it's gone it
went up and it hurts you're like no no
no and now our every dollar budget is
now consistent once a month but I look
back on what we spent on groceries two
years ago and I'm like I can't believe
how we did that and how you get it's
weird how you get used to it well I'm
not used to it like it still sucks but
like you you find this new way of
functioning and then I would say those
two can with inflation the opposite is
true when we tell people to get out of
debt and all this right these interest
rates don't affect you if you don't have
that and on the flip side if you have a
money market account or a high yield
savings account you're getting the best
return you've gotten I'm loving it and
forever so I'm like actually having
savings and not that that's going to be
like your long-term strategy as a high
yield savings account but you're it's
it's high okay Rachel you just said
something that I think I want to share
with people right now where the interest
rates are they're still historically
really low for a home mortgage but a lot
of people are sitting going it's so high
compared to 3.75 or 3.2 or 2 but here's
the deal the I just want to throw this
out there I think the housing market
will rebound when the consumer mentality
goes you know what historically
5.75 6.75 that's not bad it's going to
take a while but two years people will
adjust and that's when I think we'll see
the housing marketing boom it's like
it's gonna be okay folks all right don't
move more of your calls coming up on the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever to
bring things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
welcome back America you are joining the
conversation about your life your money
your work your relationships here on the
Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman joined by my
colleague Rachel Cruz the phone number
to jump in is triple eight eight two
five five two two five what do you want
to talk about today Rachel and I oh you
got we have a lot of fun together we'll
we'll we'll we'll leave here for you
we'll even get a little extra like we'll
go a little deeper maybe a little side
on any of those topics because you know
we've got an opinion so uh if you've
never called in before and you're going
I think I might be nervous trust me
today's the day no need to be nervous
we're going to take good care of you uh
one of the topics we talk about so much
on this show is paying off debt because
so many people are in debt and that's a
smart thing to do so is saving and
investing
but there's one key to winning with
money that a lot of people Overlook
Rachel and that's protecting your
finances from emergencies and that's
where insurance is so important now
there are 10 kinds of insurance coverage
you might need depending on where your
life is today and we've built a tool
called coverage checkup to show you what
you need or what you need to drop we'll
even rank your coverage list by
importance email it to you and then
connect you with a Ramsey trusted
insurance provider so that you can get
the right plan in place Donald H one of
our audience members said for anyone who
has not completed this checkup do it now
you never know when something will
happen and you never want your family to
be in a bad situation he's right
ramseysolutions.com checkup
ramsesolutions.com
checkup let's go to Columbus Ohio next
Josh is there Josh how can we help
well thank you for taking my call I
appreciate it what's up
um
first I I want to thank you and then
also so to get started with it
um I've been listening to you guys for a
couple months now and I've been trying
to reason in my mind not to pay off that
but I think now it's just like I should
go ahead and do it now so
um I have about 74 000 and my bank
um and I have about 45
000 and that
um and Loans so 18 500 is my car loan
and then that 26.5 as
um and student loans and then I'm trying
to also save
um for a house that I'm about to buy
from my grandpa within the next year
it's great Josh so
how can we help
so I want to make sure that
my reasoning to pay off
just to write a check for both these
loans is the best move
before I start going straight into
a down payment for that house yes sir
it's a great move yep
um question Josh how much is the house
how much will you be buying it for
um I'm planning on doing somewhere
around 150 because there's a bunch of
work I want to do to it okay
it's great
um
oh
the why behind paying off this debt and
you have the money for it so writing a
check today
uh I would say it's twofold Josh one we
have found the fastest way to build
wealth and to win with money
from point A to point B the fastest most
effective way the way that honestly will
sustain you over a long period of time
is getting out of debt when your income
comes in and it's all yours it's not
going back out into a car loan it's not
going back out into a student loan
you're going to be able to have all of
that to work for you whether you're
working for you and purchasing a home
and having that where it's going to
build equity over time it's going to
work for you having it to be able to
invest and compound interest and it
works for you over time like you're
letting your money work for you versus
working for the bank so from a
mathematical Financial standpoint it
does you so much service so much service
to have no debts and that's again on the
more tactical side and then what we
found Josh too over the years do you
know this Show's been around for what 30
years Ken and continually in this
message Josh we hear people talk about
the freedom that they feel on an
emotional a spiritual
um level I mean it's amazing even what
your body physically like what it does
to protect yourself and when you're when
you owe someone money we don't give this
enough credit of the amount of brain
power that it goes to saying okay
someone else
has a level of power over my life and
I'm not in complete autonomy someone
else has say over my life whether it's
Toyota Motor Company Sallie Mae someone
else's is latched on to you and when you
are free from that and you're free from
a system
and it it does something to you again on
a more emotional spiritual level than
most people ever talk about so that's
why we have people call in and scream
out I'm debt free because when you are
free there is a freedom there that you
just can't experience when you
financially are in this bondage so
um that that's always the thing I tell
or I tell people Josh is it's smart
financially and it's smart for just Josh
as a whole person to not owe anyone
anything so I would take that route in a
heartbeat I would take the rest of that
money that 29 000 create some level of
an emergency fund for you are you single
married kids where are you at uh with
life one kid and I'm single okay so I
would have a a nice emergency fund there
you know maybe four months what's your
take home
all right well 50. you're you're you're
you're your uh take home after tax is
fifty thousand no it's annually right so
what's your monthly take home
after time about 2600. all right so to
her point to Rachel's point oh you're
gonna feel freedom this is amazing okay
so can I just have some fun with the
numbers Josh
sure okay so if I heard you right you
have seventy four thousand dollars cash
in the bank right now and your debt
total debt is forty five thousand
correct
correct all right that leads 29 000
which is amazing at 2600 if I heard you
right take home all right so 2600 at six
months which is we say anywhere from
three to six months I'd love to see you
have a six months emergency fund I think
it'd be fantastic okay so you're looking
at uh about fifteen thousand dollars
roughly right for your for your six
months emergency fund correct
yep all right my friend that leaves you
with fourteen thousand dollars still
that you now begin to go into baby step
3B which is saving towards that house in
one check
you in one fail swoop of a just a mighty
payment right chopping down the tree of
debt my friend that's a big deal now one
other fun number what are your combined
monthly payments between the student
loan and the car
roughly well I have I haven't been
making any payments as soon well that's
true I wanted to start doing that you
got me on that um what's the car payment
oh
it's about 450 a month bro
you got fourteen thousand dollars left
over and now you've got a raise of 450 a
month these are just Rachel and to save
that down payment you're gonna have a
great down payment for 100. for 150 000
house so so that 450 we say anywhere
from five to ten percent on on a starter
home yeah uh to put down and you'll have
that so run the math on that Josh so 450
a month now that you could put towards
the down payment okay how quickly do you
get there and and you were asking I need
a good reason to do it we've given you a
good reason emotionally and spiritually
as Rachel said beautifully but just look
at the numbers my man you have a fat
emergency fund you're on your way to
that really healthy down payment for
your first home and Josh and I would
even say I I would even go a little bit
more liberal than Ken did even if you
wanted a three-month emergency fund
that's true too right I mean you could
you could cut that and that's right
that's right uh that 15 and and say you
know maybe it's more you know like six
six seven and then add more to that down
payment and then later you can bump it
up if you want but I mean you just have
you have the ability to do everything
right now is what it feels like in a
great way
um so use it to your advantage to get
you ahead financially so I in a
heartbeat would do that
um that's exciting so I think it's great
do you have any other cash Josh just
around like in any type of savings
oh um yeah I have about two thousand
just fine in cash okay that's awesome so
how would it feel Josh waking up
tomorrow knowing that you have you know
let's just pretend seven thousand
dollars saved in the bank no debt
and you're looking towards the house how
does that just feel
well that would be awesome yeah I think
it would do it Josh to cheering you up
like today it's Friday it's for all into
the weekend debt free do it do it man I
I gotta tell you if I'm you I'm trying
to get it all paid off and then really
having the greatest happy hour of all
time
celebration go celebrate that's awesome
goodness how fun is that a single dad a
young single dad starting off with his
life honestly kid most people have this
and they're starting from Ground Zero
he's got 74 000 he's saved up so he's
he's a good guy I'm like you're doing
great you're doing awesome stud big time
stud be free going into the weekend my
friend boy Monday morning's gonna feel
great awesome stuff this is the Ramsey
Show don't move
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Rachel Cruz is alongside this
hour as we are here for you triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to Seattle Washington
Karen joins us there Karen how can we
help
hi Ken and Rachel thank you for taking
my call I am an experienced registered
nurse and desire to move up in my
industry I also have a master's degree I
have taken your get clear assessment and
I have some great job examples that I
feel like would fit me however I feel
like I lack the confidence to really
move up and part of that is is that I
have a chronic health condition that at
times I'll you know has episodic you
know exacerbations and then I'm out for
work for like a day I feel like if I
want to move up into management or I
need leadership that would I couldn't
really perform or not really make them
happy I can't really resolve this but it
does seem to kind of cause some anxiety
and create that mental barrier in my
head I'm a smart experienced nurse I
know I can do it
but I have two job interviews lined up
with VP Executives should I tell them
about this concern
well um let me address that in a second
you're smart you're experience that
tells me that this is even though this
is a nuisance this health issue and it
kind of comes and goes it doesn't seem
to me that it's hurting your job
performance overall is this true
no not at all so your current leaders if
I were talking their current supervisors
I said hey tell me about Karen what are
they going to say
um actually I just heard from them last
week it goes Kim we can't say enough how
um your job does not go unnoticed you
are excellent and every every manager
really uh really Praises my work okay so
I think it's my I think it's mentally a
lock for me it is listen listen this is
huge
you have got to focus on what you just
heard from your managers what you've
always heard from your managers and the
season that this started popping up you
have been able to manage it so now while
I'm not a medical doctor if your medical
doctor is saying hey look when this
episodic thing happens you gotta take
some time off but if it doesn't affect
you other than that and you're not
missing too much time then your fear
while understandable is not reasonable
your fear is not reasonable there is
nothing keeping you from doing the job
of managing other nurses just because we
know this to be true because it hasn't
kept you from taking care of your
patients true or false
but that's true it has not impacted my
ability to do any of my job performance
at all so now back to your question
because it will not impact your ability
to do your job
I don't think you got to lead with it I
don't think you're being dishonest by
not talking about it it's just you can
just share as you get closer to the
process if they make an offer now this
is where I would bring it up you know if
they go hey we really want to do this
just go listen I just want to let you
know that I have this issue from time to
time and it has not affected my ability
to do my job you're going to come to
this job with rave reviews so it says
you'll have references and reviews and
you're going to be able to see it for
you and it doesn't you don't use up all
your sick time
is that true yeah that's true I mean if
it happens I might have to take a a full
day off or half a day off but after that
I'm right into my work well then I don't
think this is any anybody how often does
that happen Karen I'm just curious
um sometimes sometimes there's nothing
in a month sometimes one once or twice
like this month it happened four times a
half a day here full day there
um but I have what they call flma
paperwork with my current dog for
intermittently so you know that I'm
covered I'm not just calling out for no
reason sure no totally Karen I I I
listen
I don't want you to believe this lie
anymore and the LIE is is that I'm not
going to be able to do the job of
leading and caring for other people
because of this and they won't give me a
shot I just don't think that's true I
think you walk forward head high
shoulders back and you've got some real
facts here to kind of you know conflict
with this fear you've got look look I
understand why you feel this way but you
agree it's not reasonable yes
I I agree this is not reasonable and I
know it's been stuck in my head and
hearing you sounds too can I say this
just even from talking to you for two
minutes
you're such a kind person and there's
maybe even a moral dilemma there in you
too that's like I want to
not that I'm scared I'm not going to get
the job but I'm like I feel this
responsibility as this kind person to
let them in on something you know so
what Ken is saying I think is great
advice I don't think you lead with it
because it doesn't affect your work but
at the end I think you would sleep
better at night knowing hey I
communicated a concern that I have and
here here it is but here's also the
evidence and the patterns of what occurs
at work when it happens and your your
reviews and your references and all that
is going to speak for you to show you to
show them no Karen is a she's a hard
worker she's good at what she does and
she can take this role because that's
what they're going to say about you
Karen because it's who you are yeah you
got it it is it is yeah but tell them if
it makes you sleep good at night too
Karen that's that's important
okay well I've got an interview in a
couple more hours with the VP and
another VP call on Monday and I know I
got that confidence I know I can do it
then lead with it I think I just yeah
and I I need a leap with that yeah
just mention it down the line if it gets
more serious but right now this is about
you the candidate and you the person who
wants the job and why that's what you
focus on in these initial interviews
there's no need to create fear and
phobias tell them to call Ken Coleman or
Rachel Cruz and we will vouch I love
that actually we will be a reference I
love that uh let's go to John now in
Valdosta Georgia that's down deep south
in Georgia John how can we help
hey there guys thanks for taking my call
sure
John we got about two and a half minutes
so uh hit us with your questions so we
can spend the most time possible helping
you out
all right so uh I'm currently active
duty military and with that I will be
locked at my next base for a year okay
so do I use the VA home loan to set
myself up for a house down there uh
while I know I'm a lot better for a year
or do I just kind of continue renting
continue renting
for sure yeah if you're if you're going
to be in a home less than five years
there's no there's there's no purpose
honestly in buying because you're not
going to get the equity out that you
want and even how the how the market is
now it doesn't give you enough time to
write out anything that could be that
could happen here in the next you know
couple months we're just talking about
the FED raising rates again like so for
sure John I would rent uh until you are
somewhere long term but thank you John
for your service where are you deployed
at right now
yeah thank you sir and uh what's your
long-term plan what's your long-term
plan in the military how many more years
do you see yourself serving just to kind
of see the back end of this deal
you see so that that's the scary part is
I'm coming up on my contract uh so I
have guaranteed a year okay and then if
I I have to re-enlist so that's another
four years and that would put me at 11
and if I'm at 11 I might as well do 20
right right yeah well okay so we don't
have time to get into that um but make
the best let me say this make the best
long-term decision for you uh look long
term where you want to be 20 years from
now and let that guide whether or not
you sign back up but to Rachel's point
the reason I asked that question she's
right rental is is gives you freedom I
don't want you having too much pressure
then it's already there to decide am I
going to sign up and be in the military
for this that's a lot on your shoulders
you don't need a house and a mortgage
leaning on you one way or the other so I
love her advice there and that's why I
wanted to ask that question so John stay
renting you're not throwing your money
away you're actually giving yourself
more freedom and options to live the
life that you want to live long term so
again thank you sir that's a great Point
uh Ken because when you attach something
like a mortgage which we always say
around here which is true most people
with their primary home it's the largest
purchase they're going to make so you're
going to have that responsibility not
just being a homeowner but long term
having that and we don't want that to
sway a decision that you make long term
with your job and your career and what
you choose to do to be able to have no
strings attached make a very clear
decision for you John and what you want
is the best and then if you settle
somewhere long term buy the house she is
Rachel Cruz thank you my friend great
hour I'm Ken Coleman James Childs our
fearless producer and the crew behind
the glass thank you guys for keeping us
afloat this hour you America is why we
do the show it's your show this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey show where we help you win in
your life specifically your money your
work and your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman Rachel Cruz joins me this hour
the phone number is
888-825-5225 that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's get it
started right here in our backyard
Nashville Tennessee Austin is there
Austin how can we help
hey hope you guys are doing well uh
thanks for taking my call uh I am
wanting your input uh my wife and I are
in baby step two and just kind of
plugging away but we just found out that
my wife is pregnant with our first all
right all right congratulations yeah
thank you thank you
um it still kind of doesn't feel real
yeah and we are wanting to you know
we're considering looking at our debt
and everything and I wanted to get some
input on whether or not we should
consider selling the house using all
that equity and then just wiping out all
the debt and just kind of basically
starting over okay so how much you guys
make a year
um I make 30 000 working in Ministry and
she makes about 35
000 uh as a therapist okay so 65 uh how
much debt do you guys have
uh we got 50 000 in student loans 25 000
in credit cards and ten thousand on a
car
okay 85 is that 85k total
yeah and then we've got a mortgage we
have 254 left on the mortgage but the
house we could probably sell it for
about 370.
okay
um
man y'all have a lot of debt
and with this and with the income
you okay so here here's my hesitation
Austin when I'm talking to you about
this
because first and foremost now that you
guys are expecting I would recommend not
making a big move right now on either
ends uh but just pile up cash we always
say to pause baby step two
uh while you you know are expecting make
sure that Mama's good baby is good if
you needed some extra cash on hand we
want that available to you uh during the
pregnancy and after Labor delivery and
then we can go back to this so all I
don't want you to do anything major and
not for nine months I mean I want you to
really wait can I can I throw an
alternative in here I just wanna I wanna
talk through this yes too uh but I
understand what you're saying can you
guys even pile up cash given that you
guys have a somewhat limited income what
is can you even pile up cash without you
having to go work extra
yeah we uh based off of just a regular
income not a lot of wiggle room there I
mean I right and door dashing and I'm in
the process of getting my real estate
license all right so let me ask you this
all right because I just want to get
Rachel's take on this because I have an
aggressive approach doesn't mean it's no
he should do all right is this house
that you're in now is this your Forever
house is this a house you guys are
absolutely in love with or do you
consider this a starter house and you
definitely see a different housing
situation down the road
uh definitely not where we point to be
long term I would sell the house I found
out about this we were thought we were
going to move out of state in the next
three years all right so Austin I would
sell a house and I want Rachel to
disagree with me here
um this is my this is what I would do if
I were you I wrote down the numbers I
would sell a house because you guys have
a lot of debt and I and with this baby
coming I want you to get a fresh start
you're a young couple this is not a
long-term play for you guys the value of
this house it's not a big time
investment play that you could live in
even if you paid it off so if I got the
numbers right after Realtors fees you're
going to walk away somewhere in the
hundred thousand range you'll have left
over is that about right
yeah okay that takes care of all of the
debt we are debt free we got 15K left
which is a which based on your income is
a really nice emergency fund we're at
baby step three baby comes yep and that
gives us a little bit of margin that's
that margin because they can't really
save and stack cash right now with their
current income so that 15K is that hey
that gives us a really nice emergency
fund if something health issue wise with
the baby it just gives us a cushion then
once baby gets here we decide what your
wife's gonna do what that's going to
look like uh I like you renting right
now and resetting with this new life
that you have and then we're resetting
if you will from baby step three and
essentially you would be moving into
what we call baby step 3B beginning to
save towards that next house Rachel
that's what I would do it take a lot of
pressure off of Mom and Dad here as they
begin to a new chapter of life
I like this move I like this move a lot
I would sell yeah so so it's that option
which is more the aggressive route or
it's hey we're gonna just knock out the
set but but you have to remember your
wife's income is basically going to be
going away after she has the baby if
she's not gonna be working uh so it's up
to you so it's going to be years and
years and years and years of paying off
this debt so what were you guys leaning
to before you called us I'm curious
uh we've been talking about it the last
couple weeks
um we decided that we were just going to
keep plugging away I'm about to get my
real estate license so we're going to
use that as income to just all right I
interrupted Rachel on that so this plays
into that yeah so again I don't think
there's a right or wrong curios in my
only hesitation and or challenge I would
say to you Austin if you went kids rock
because I think that that's an option
that's a very reasonable option I don't
think it's extreme at all I think if you
guys are not if you don't see anything
moving it's going to take a lot of
movement to get the step paid off where
you guys are with your income but you're
getting your real estate license all
that so here's what I'll say if you
choose option A Ken's choice
you're wiping it all out you're wiping
it all out without really much sacrifice
yeah you're selling your home but
there's not a ton of change that is
occurring because you're going to get a
lump sum you're going to shift that
money to the debt and it's all going to
be done versus going through the process
not that it's wrong to do that but you
you guys have 25 000 in credit card debt
Austin you guys have a car you can't
afford you took out loans for school
which again you're normal
but you have to know that like you you
there's a level of pain I kind of want
you guys to feel because I want you to
think I will never ever ever ever ever
go back and 25 000 of credit card debt
for whatever reason that you guys are in
like you have to live a different life
than what you've been living and people
that walk through the debt-free process
there is so much sacrifice there is so
much like I hate this I can't wait to be
out that they will they will not they
don't want to go back but when people
get an inheritance or they the sale of
their house and they get a lump sum
which is a gift that's a blessing to be
able in one fail sweep sweep wipe
everything out again amazing and from
paper like you're going to be able to
move forward quickly but please you and
your wife have to sit down and promise
each other that we're not going to get
back into this because what this debt is
is decisions that are made from a
lifestyle perspective especially the
credit card you have to remember that so
Austin if you guys do this and you do
option A again great option
um you you have to really feel deep in
your soul that our Behavior has to
change we can't because if you keep
believing like living like you've been
living there's not going to be another
house that's going to wipe out the debt
you know
it's interesting you make a very good
point but the real estate license and
the real estate license could be yeah I
I want him to go with a and take the
commitment I I think that I want him to
go a but to your point you make a very
good point it's the right point I didn't
make it I'm glad you did it's right
don't just think oh we wiped this out
quickly and then we're tempted to play
with debt again yep uh don't do this
unless you're serious about never taking
on debt again good good good point
sell the house this is the rainy show
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
I'm Ken Coleman I'm joined by Rachel
Cruz and we are here for you this hour
taking your calls about your life your
money your work your relationships those
three areas tend to always be connected
one way or another triple eight eight
two five five two two five eight eight
two five five two two five Rachel you
ready for our question of the day yep
our question of the day is brought to
you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services neighborly has 19 service
Brands Nationwide and a network of local
service pros Molly made Mr Rooter
plumbing and Lawn Pride to name just a
few visit neighborly.com to find
available service providers near you
today's question comes from Jenny in
Oregon oh my goodness get out the Pepsi
AC we have over a hundred thousand
dollars in car loans 55 600 on a 2019
Tundra thirty six thousand one hundred
dollars on a 2016 Toyota 4Runner twelve
thousand dollars on a 2018 Honda Accord
I
I would like to dump ninety one thousand
seven hundred of this debt by selling
the tundra and the Forerunner however my
husband doesn't like paying the stupid
tax on it we are very underwater on the
tundra and I have high miles on the
Forerunner we have listed them and have
had low offers but no real bites if we
took the offers and got a loan for the
difference we could be
thirty three thousand dollars in the
hole but the miles keep going up on both
and I'm ready to get rid of them now she
writes in all caps
Jenny's had it Jenny is motivated she
ain't happy she says what do you think
should we wait for a better offer while
the clock ticks on value or cut bait now
I would like to hire Jenny as a lawyer
she's fantastic she's using great phrase
she's leading us right into this Rachel
uh or should we Face the stupid text
this would free up 1900 a month to throw
at other debt our take home each month
is approximately ten thousand dollars
and we have 277 thousand dollars in debt
that does not include our home so
dumping the vehicles would be a huge and
she goes all caps here
now I am Mr uh uh uh get rid of the cars
immediately and find the the cheaper car
it's a sport for me now because I've got
three teens yeah I got one in a car you
can find them find the cheap cars I got
two more on the way next year and I'm
always looking and what did he finds Ken
what do you think very serviceable
decent looking cars in the five to seven
thousand dollar range yep and I'm not
making this up now are they higher miles
yes uh are is the carpet perfect no yeah
but I mean look if I'm trying to get out
of debt here and I gotta get from point
A to point B as I said earlier in the
show nobody cares what you're driving
and here's the other thing if they do
care pull around back that's park
somewhere else okay but the low so I was
saying this on the show last week but I
had the car mom on Instagram live with
me and she saw this she's awesome she
has she knows everything about car she's
like my age and she knows everything
about cars so she was talking about
though that the high mileage myth it's
become a myth she's like these cars can
run well beyond 200 000 miles forever
because they they are so well made so
let me tell you this so the whole high
mileage thing I'm like whatever like buy
the high mileage car you're not going to
be in it forever no but get rid oh I
would get rid of this stuff in a
heartbeat cars make me like you sell
them all so Jenny our answer is
um I'd rather be thirty three thousand
dollars in debt than a hundred thousand
dollars in that yeah and you've she's
laid it all out Jenny you don't need us
to teach you on this one you just you
just wanting our approval and you've
already paid the stupid tax by paying a
car payment every month at this point so
yeah I think you got to sit down with
the hubs and you got to change his mind
from the focus on the stupid tax next to
what this really does for us every month
real numbers he's worried about the
stupid taxes two thousand dollars a
month
it's all day every day y'all by the way
all day every day I'm no car mom all
right but I will tell you as I'm looking
at cars for my kids
um you have to there's a calculated risk
here but you can get really nice luxury
cars and I'm just gonna pull out a
couple of Brands a Mercedes or a BMW
that may only be about 10 years old are
in fantastic shape on the outside and
the inside now these cars do cost more
to repair so you you'd have to have that
emergency fund and margin but you can
buy them less than ten thousand dollars
because you know why because those
owners of those cars are taking car
payments and they're just re-upping
every time the next model comes out so
their their value goes down but you
could you could be like I don't want to
drive a beater you could be in a nice
looking Mercedes from like 2007 2010 and
again if the previous owner took good
care of them sure and you have the
emergency fund to fix them when they
they will run for 250 300 000 miles
that's right I'm just pointing that out
yep and you could go even cheaper on a
Toyota yes like in her case she'd go she
we would say you know you drive the you
drive the crappy car right but to your
point even people yeah on baby steps
four through six like
if your if your net worth is not a
million dollars that's what we always
say it needs to be in order to take the
hit of buying a brand new car there are
still night to your point there are
still nice cars out there that are used
like this whole idea that you can't find
one yeah and you're not embarrassed by
the way to drive up on these things no
well that and uh I'm driving an older
Mercedes and you remember you saw it
when I got it yeah I was a kid nice car
I had no idea I mean it's a 2013. yeah
would have no idea it's 10 years old you
didn't believe me when I told you well
in most 10 year old car and again most
people are not car people most people on
the interstate that you're passing at 70
miles an hour they don't know they don't
care
uh the psychology of money that book the
author pointed this out and I've never
forgotten it because I'm like it is so
true and I'm not a big car person so it
doesn't relate to me 100 but he was like
whenever you draw whenever you see a
cool car you're looking at the car right
rarely are you looking at the driver and
being like cool guy he's awesome
he's they're just like what use this car
man what is
but they're looking at the car all right
they don't like you they don't care
about you they're not even really
looking at you but they're looking at
the cool like you know we passed that
exotic car there's a there's a there's
an exotic car yeah that passes on our
street not our neighborhood street but
like our one of our main streets and we
see it and it's blue so it's very
obvious but you'll see it kind of around
they usually are by the way and I'm like
and the windows or tenants I'm like you
don't even see the person that's in
there but you see this car confession
which is fun fine but I'm just saying
like again to that point
you're driving something that people
aren't even looking at you for for some
weird identity thing so forget it I have
a confession that may actually shed
light on what you're saying or it's just
going to expose me as being a jerk can't
wait I love jerky Canada when I see
those kind of cars those high-end exotic
cars driving by
what do you think I love jerky can it
just hit me uh
we judge them
and I go what kind of complex are they
making up for anybody else
I I immediately go Oh you gotta have the
cobalt blue fancy car so that everybody
in your life thinks that you're special
what are you covering up what I think
what do you I don't want to be like that
guy anybody else in the city am I the
only one that thinks that way I
immediately start judging you not
respecting you sure and that's more of
that maybe that's something crazy exotic
but if you see like a night like a new
like yeah escalators no no I'm talking
about stream your neighbor yeah he's got
a neighbor but it's the like I'm sorry
I'm just offended neighbors no the point
is the Exotic Car the tinted windows
it's really loud it's like look at me
that's what I think of that person I
know I know or I just think so what's
the real of your point what's the real
reward all right if you're if you're
taking it out on the racetrack and you
got
awful amounts of money and that's
probably my that's one thing I'm just
like you you're stuck with a 1200 car
1200 car payment probably more for these
kind of 1500 yeah it's like what's the
whole point you are driving something
that's losing value every time you burn
Rubber pal right absolutely you know I
know I don't know there's some nice cars
out there and I love a nice car so don't
get me wrong I I know I think it's great
you were griping about your minivan
though the other day on social media I
wasn't criping I just said I acknowledge
that I drive a minivan and every time I
do my dog does die a little bit because
there's too many of them I've been
waiting for this moment to confront you
on this I tried to talk you out of it
no but you said your soul dies when you
get the money a little bit get a
Suburban no because the minivan is it's
amazing
in that minivan can no and you have
three freaking small children that take
a peanut butter sandwich and do this and
rub it on the seats I don't want a
Suburban all right thank you for a
rebuttal third of the cost
three kids hold on we had three kids and
never once did I go gosh I wish the door
when those doors open and slam no no not
at all nobody cares sliding door it's a
myth this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back America you've joined the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show I'm
Kidd Coleman she is Rachel Cruz the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and I've got something I got to tell you
about where is that oh yes here we go
I'm in the middle I'm I'm landing the
plane if you will I've got three classes
left on my Financial Peace University
class and personalities or coordinated
class it's great fun Wednesday Friday
night group so like after Today's Show
I'll get a little bit of green tea with
honey get my energy up rest my voice got
to get home we do it on the back patio
with the wooden American flag behind me
that's fine thank you very much and uh
great crowd um just people signed up for
a Wednesday night and a Friday night
yeah I get the Wednesday night but uh
Friday night fbu class uh it is we're
having a we're having people getting out
of debt there we're having a party
they're hanging around it's fantastic
they're not going out on Friday night
well let me tell you saving their money
it works the class works and it's just
got an unbelievable track record because
we have a lot of people that are coming
in new to the show Rachel's you know you
see the numbers so exciting to see more
and more people discovering the show via
podcast via YouTube and and learning
about the process they listen to the
calls but they haven't truly decided to
jump in yet you know you're learning
about what to do with your money based
on how we teach but you haven't believed
it and started doing it and uh as Davis
said for decades personal finance is 80
Behavior 20 head knowledge so the proven
way to change your behavior is through
the knowledge but also the community and
the accountability of a Financial Peace
University class it is the difference
between trying to get in shape on your
own versus hiring a trainer so
it's worked for Millions it's a nine
week commitment and you'll never handle
money the same way again don't just
listen to the show commit to doing what
it takes to win by joining an fbu class
at ramseysolutions.com FPU that's
ramseysolutions.com
slash FPU Laura is up next in Salem
Oregon Laura how can we help
hi thank you for
thank you
um red Total Money Makeover years ago
before the pandemic and started focusing
on paying off my 200 plus thousand
dollars in student loans then the
pandemic hit yeah
um then the pandemic hit and I kind of
fell off the Focus wagon but luckily I
had my auto savings like set up so I
stopped making payments to my student
loans but set everything up to auto save
so I'm now to the point where I can
between my savings and my investments
that I've been playing with over the
last few years I can by the end of this
summer I should be able to pay off all
my student loans wow 200 000. that's
amazing
it's well I was paying on them I mean
I've been out of school for 14 years so
it's been taking it's a lot it's not
just in the last time down to 149 and
right now good for you um and so it's
it's been a long process but
um and I don't have any credit card that
I do have a loan on my solar panels but
that's it and then my mortgages so I
have my question is I have a primary
mortgage and then I also have a rental
house and I know you guys always say to
sell the rental but my the rental was
purchased for my mother and my sister
because they were getting priced out of
their rent and so my mom has since
passed and now it's just my sister on
her own in my rental house she has been
diligently paying me and I get about 400
a month income past the mortgage from
that every month so I don't want to kick
her out and sell it so I just need to
know which one I should focus on first
the rental or my primary as far as
paying off once I'm done with my student
loans this summer
okay so once you pay off your loans how
much is the solar panels
like thirty thousand Thirty okay my next
offset might they do offset that my my
power bill so it's not
I mean yes it's a loan but it's not
costing me anything
uh
uh so yeah because you're not paying
like utilities and stuff correct is what
you're saying but you are having to pay
monthly
payments right so instead of instead of
paying a utility bill every month I pay
the solar panel right but you had to but
but that is debt though I mean you still
yes I hear what you're saying but that
yeah next yes that's yeah exactly that's
what make sure we're on the same page
there okay
um yeah so I honestly Laura I mean I
would we teach smallest to largest so
whenever you you cash out you said you
had some Investments are they
non-retirement
correct yeah I have about a half million
in retirement 401K oh good for you I've
been maxing that out since I got out of
school okay good for you
um how much is in the other Investments
uh so I got about 77 000 in my other
Investments and I've got 66 000 just in
a high interest savings okay so I'm like
together I've got 143 but by the end of
the summer I should have the 149. okay
perfect
um yeah I mean I would I would lump
those solar panels into that would be
the next thing I would and technically
with the debt snowball knock out the
solar panels and then have some of the
student loans left
to then knock out you know as as the
year goes on how how much money do you
make a year
uh about 145 okay I'm not counting any
over time okay perfect
yeah so I would attack the go ahead and
get the solar panels out of the way so
that that monthly payment that's going
to the solar panels and not having to
pay utilities
that you have that so that you can you
know that's extra cash too to throw at
the student loan so I would knock out
that smallest one first at 30 000. pay
off the student loans then once you're
done there save up that emergency funds
and then you're still funding retirement
what how would you feel about pausing
retirements
that makes me nervous
yeah so I did how much a month is going
to retirement
um well 15 is going to my 401k okay
and that Maxes it maxes out usually in
August or October I mean and so actually
what I did when I saw how close I was to
being able to pay off these student
loans I backed off my retirement
investment for the summer so that I can
take that money and put towards this and
then all right back up after the student
loans you have 500 000 in retirement
you're doing great
if you paused for a year
because we want to free up as much cash
as possible to get all of this paid off
and and again I'm not talking yet your
mortgage but even just this because
you'll still have some Consumer Debt
left or some of the student loans left
even after you cash out everything and
with the solar panels so if I were you
Laura I would pause everything and I
know you hate that and that's so scary
but you're doing fine I mean you're
doing you're doing great I also I also
have a 14 year old that's starting high
school that I need to put some money
aside for college yes yes and you will
do all of that you've got lots of
buckets to put money in I know and that
and that's what's hard Laura is you're
trying to do it all you're trying to do
it all what I want you to focus on one
thing and I want you to focus on getting
these solar panels and the student loan
paid off everything needs to pause yes
what's the rental situation can I stick
my nose in this what's what are the
numbers really quick on the rental
so I owe 130 and it's probably worth
about 250.
um I the they I get 1200 a month rent
and the payment's only 800. I'd sell the
rental tomorrow I'd put it I'd list it
tomorrow my sister is living in it well
she can live somewhere else
for that price honestly honestly she
can't rent I understand I've got a good
price I understand but but look what you
could do if it's you could sell it for
250 it's worth 130 take away the
Realtors fees on there we're talking
about a massive life change
I mean just what we teach you should not
have this rental given the debt you've
got
so I bought the rental originally for my
mother who passed
she was being priced out of her
for basically forced her to retire
because of medical things and so she was
living on Social Security and her the
option was for her to live with me or to
find her a place that I could basically
all right real quick because we don't
have a lot of time I got to cut you off
because are you single married what's
your situation
I would listen to me I would sell the
house the rental and sister can come
live with you and pay you some rent
you're gonna get this well okay here's
the deal
you don't need a rental does your does
your sister is she not able to work
oh she's working yes she's that's she's
paying the full and she's a grown woman
I know Laura there might be some you
could be oh my gosh I'd sell this rental
Rachel I hear your heart in it Laura and
I think it's okay to to help but also we
want to we want you to win Laura
um and and your sister may have to make
some hard grown-up decisions on her own
too and you not having to be the one
caring caretaking mats for her
so I just want you to wrestle with this
question how would selling that rental
change your financial picture wrestle
with that then decide what you want to
do this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Rachel Cruz this
hour the phone number for you to jump in
to talk about your life specifically
your money
your relationships and your work is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five Bryce joins us now in
Columbia Missouri Bryce how can we help
okay thank you for taking my call guys I
really appreciate it
okay so I'm a junior at the University
of Missouri studying finance and
Investment Banking basically what my
question is is what can I do to be more
competitive in the job market since I'm
attending a non-target school these jobs
usually recruit from Ivy League schools
like that because I'm going to be
graduating with in between 120
000 and 130 000 in student loan debt now
I've already taken some steps to you
know help me when I get out I'm in the
KPMG Financial advising accelerator okay
good so I have that on my resume already
is that what specifically are you
looking for
I just
I disagree on par with ivy league
students you know because
no no no I'm sorry it was a bad question
on my part what are you looking for
financial advising Investments like what
what's the specific Lane that seat on
the bus you're wanting to land
but I would say Financial advising
that's what I'm mostly looking for right
now gotcha
um
well it's a it's a good question I
understand the question I will tell you
that anybody that that claims to say
well there's a very clear answer to that
um I think they'd be wrong this is going
to be just straight opinion
um okay I will tell you that uh you the
candidate are what they are looking at
more than the name on your diploma
now that's not true across the board I
mean that you could talk to you could
talk to 10 hiring managers and eight
would agree with me or two wooden or
five would and they might say well if
you're from an Ivy League school I'm
going to pay attention to that that that
may be true but I will tell you getting
into the initial interview process
it won't have any effect at all if
you're just gonna apply the old school
way which is I'm going to put a resume
in and I'm going to go into the system
then I can tell you at the level you're
going in they are using artificial
intelligence to pre-screen candidates
it's just on some level you're dealing
with that so the ivy league thing is it
going to stand out more or not I don't
know that there's a whole lot of
evidence that says it does it might open
a door but I'm not I don't believe it's
going to win you the job so here's the
advantage that that I will tell you that
I believe you can have
relationships
so let's just say
you want to go work for KPMG just using
them they're big time firm all right so
you you identify a job for KPMG that you
want and and you're up against you know
Ivy Leaguers what will make the
difference is is if you have a
relationship connection you may have a
one-to-one or it may be one to three
what I mean by one to three is I know
somebody that knows somebody that knows
somebody over there and and they are
making a call on your behalf emailing on
your behalf they are submitting your
resume with a letter of recommendation
to say I know Bryce Bryce just graduated
from boom and this is what his GPA is
and this is what he's done and they are
presenting you with their credibility
that I think is the only viable
competitive advantage that you can have
over an Ivy League or if you have the
same degrees and virtually similar gpas
I think it's going to come down to
relationships where someone's vouching
for you and that goes along way
go ahead
I said so so basically networking
getting to know people who already
worked there that way it gets me past
the AI screening process 100 you're
gonna you're still gonna go through the
AI because you're still gonna have to go
through the formal application process
but the point is is now you're seen if
you just go through the AI thing you
don't know what AI is looking for that
company's not going to tell you what
what they're looking for on the resume
so it's a relationship situation so for
instance uh you want to be thinking
about your local connections
guys and gals that you know that are in
this field do they know somebody you see
where I'm going here like yeah you
you've got to start digging now that's
for the competitive Advantage how do I
be more competitive that works by the
way whether I'm competing against an Ivy
Leaguer or not uh relationships and
referrals I'm like that's that will get
your thing pulled out of a stack that's
the idea because yeah there's an actual
person like with Ken's saying that
that's looking at it and that knows your
name but I also want to encourage you
the course that you're taking now above
and beyond your schooling anything like
that any additional qualification
certifications any of that I'd stack all
of those those are worth uh the time and
the effort as long as you're not going
into debt to pay for these things these
are all going to be valuable but it's
all about relationships relationships
relationships I'll tell you what uh hang
on the line I'm going to give you a copy
of my book The Proximity principle which
is a deep dive on this
the power of proximity is just simply
this when I'm around the people that are
doing what I want to do and I'm in the
places where that's being done
opportunities will come to me and so
this is about the right people the right
place it's a deep dive super easy to
read hang on the line it's a bit of a
guidebook for this very thing making the
right connections so that opportunities
actually come to you let's go now to
Jake in the Twin Cities I always love do
you know the Twin Cities putting you on
the spot call Minneapolis there you go
yes don't mess with Rachel on the basic
trivia folks she's got it Jake how can
we help
yeah um thank you so much for taking my
call this morning I'm sorry this
afternoon my wife and I just had a baby
about six months ago oh congratulations
thank you appreciate it you have a
minivan Jake oh we do we don't have the
minivan and we don't have any plans too
but good for you Jake Paul strong stay
strong
um that is part of the reason I'm
calling is because
um we before having a child my wife
worked and now after having her child my
wife decided to be a stay-at-home mom
and we decided to a couple of years ago
to buy a truck
um and before we started listening to
Dave Ramsey we took out a loan on it
um we've been pretty smart in all the
other things so the only loans that we
have is this truck loan and our mortgage
we're trying to decide if we should pay
off the loan with our savings sell the
truck and you know maybe buy a beater
car or continue to you know try to take
every single penny that we have and kind
of go gazelle intense and trying to pay
off the truck yeah with new cash coming
in
um how much do you guys make a year
so I do software sales so I make a
hundred thousand dollar base but last
year I probably did about 200 000. no
good for you Jake that's awesome yeah
how much is left on the car line
it's about twenty nine thousand dollars
29 what do you guys have in savings
yeah so for cash we have about fifty
thousand dollars in cash
but that would deplete our six-month
emergency savings which I put aside
quite a bit just because we wanted to
make sure that we had enough you know
having a little one and my wife's not
working anymore we wanted to have six
months worth of savings instead of uh
three minutes and so that's most of our
six months worth of savings there okay
um I would
sell the truck and buy a minivan I'm
just kidding Jake I would I would take
the savings and I'd pay not a bad idea
and I would pay off the truck I would
pay it off and then and you guys have
plenty of cash you're in a very stable
job right if you were transitioning jobs
or there was Big Stuff happening then I
feel like you'd be like okay yes having
a lot of money in the bank like okay
that could be really scary but you guys
are fine Jake you're fine I would
totally take that pay off the truck bump
it back up to six months which your
income is fabulous so you guys are gonna
be able to do that really quickly
and then just work yourself down the
baby steps so if I were you today yeah
uh I would I just paid off paid off what
kind of truck is it
it's a Ford F-150 and it's got the
extended cab
oh yeah it's got all the fun features
make a good income so your truck is not
out of proportion it's to you guys so
um it pay it off and I just want to
point out to Rachel that you have the
F-150 with the extended cab and the baby
seat goes fine in there you have the
carrier Jake don't you you have the
carry you gotta you'll need sliding
doors Jake's strong he can put the baby
in the back it's gonna be okay stay at
home mom you gotta build that muscle
yeah uh Jake paid off have a great
weekend with a debt-free home awesome
and and a heartbeat I would but I mean
paid off trucks I I appreciate the
caution right new baby life is Shifty I
get it you guys are good you're in a
very stable position job wise you'll get
that emergency fund back up that truck
payment is a raise yes that's coming
right back to you to racial's points so
really nothing to be afraid of good
logic but you're okay pay that truck off
and uh don't buy the minivan Rachel Cruz
great hour thanks for being with me
James Charles and the crew keeping us on
the air and you America even those that
drive a minivan we love you this is the
Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey show where we help you win in
your life specifically your money your
relationships and your work I'm Ken
Coleman joined by The Fabulous the
incomparable Rachel Cruz's sour you like
that that was great great work yeah
great adjective yeah there you go I
studied all day for that triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
phone number and Rachel and I would love
to help you we really enjoy this and we
have so many new people coming in all
the time and so I want to point out two
things if you're new to this show and
you're trying to figure out some of the
the language we use we're talking about
baby steps and then the different
numbers and all that I want to make sure
that you know that we have a get started
button at ramseysolutions.com that's the
mothership the website there and you can
just take just a few minutes a brief
survey and we kind of let you know where
you are in this journey that we call
Financial Peace and and the baby steps
and you get caught up pretty quick and
now you feel like okay I I understand
how all this works because we're quite
frankly we challenge you with some
pretty counter-cultural ideas about
money and so we want to get you caught
up so go do that uh it's the get started
button at ramseysolutions.com all right
let's do what we're here to do is just
encouraging coach people Audrey's up
next in Chicago Illinois Audrey how can
we help
hi my husband
my husband
has about six years ago and
um shortly after that we purchased an
apartment
um because my daughter was paying
ridiculous amount of rent in the city so
we thought why don't we buy something
and have her rent it so she did so um I
think we're about a little bit over
halfway uh done paying that and
um last year I lost my job and we
purchased a property that we wanted
um
for planning toward their future which
uh for our retirement
um because
um we live in the Midwest and it's cold
so we want to go somewhere warm because
um I have some health issues so anyway
as long story short I'm wondering if we
would be better off selling the
apartment that we have the condo and
having less sets because now I feel like
I'm not used to having any debt and so
I'm wondering if we have taken on too
much well let's run through the numbers
real quick for Rachel and she'll walk
you through this so how much do we owe
on the apartment condo
80 000. what's it worth
um it's probably worth 175. good and
then what's the other properties that
just dirt somewhere where it's warm or
Does it include a house what is that
it's a condo
oh so we have an apartment and a condo
yeah two condos two condos we have one
condo in the city that pretty much pays
for itself my daughter graduated school
and now she's our renter so that
property pays for itself okay I know it
pays for itself how much is that though
um we financed it for 15 years and the
mortgage payment is um a thousand twenty
okay how much is how much do you owe on
that condo
80. that's the one she gave me oh I'm
sorry the first one I apologize oh my
God it's all confused because I didn't
understand so you have a second condo
and give us the numbers on that second
condo
what's it worth and
yeah 2 30. and what is your monthly
payment on that
um
haven't we haven't taken out a loan on
it yet but it's out of the country and
we were required to pay half up front
now that being said um I just want to
make sure that we've got all the numbers
so you put down half of the 130.
no it was actually 250.
okay
but we put half down
you paid 130 because but you took a loan
out for the 130. we have not yet we have
to do that once it's done being built
because
um
all right so here's what I'm asking
Audrey have you put any money towards
this condo that's out of the country
we've been calling a condo too have you
put any money yes how much did you put
down
1 30. okay that's what all right so okay
and it's worth 230 if I wrote if I if I
heard you correct okay yeah yeah okay
it's worth about between 230 and 250.
okay but the 130 though Audrey was alone
you guys took out
no it was cash when I got that go from
yeah when I got left go for my job I got
a severance package and I said it's not
making any money in the bank we need to
start planning for retirement so let's
invest it and something I got you and
you have no other debt everything else
is paid for
everything else is paid for and how how
much do you guys make a year
well before it used to be 200 but now
it's cut in half because I don't I'm not
working
okay okay so one so 100 100 Grand a year
okay yeah yeah
um
and how soon are you guys to retirement
how soon will you guys be actually
utilizing this condo
condo number two probably in like seven
years okay and you plan on an option to
rent it okay but you plan on using it
within the seven years but you think
will you be there full time will you
sell the comb that you guys currently
have
to go to this condo full time or you
keep both was your plan
well we've thought about actually
selling our house and then maybe getting
uh a townhouse or something to not have
to worry about the maintenance but for
now with the housing market I've been
told that it's not your benefit to do
that so we're fine in our house now but
I don't know what our plan is for the
future yep and then the other 130 is
going to be due when
next
um probably next summer next summer so a
year from now
yeah and we've been looking at options
on how we're going to finance that
whether to do a HELOC or uh
um I think there are a couple of options
a HELOC or uh I forgot what the other
one is called man Audrey I know how much
you guys have in retirement
um in my 401k I have over a million
probably one point 1.2 okay okay my
husband probably is close to a million
and your primary home is paid off
yeah our property home is paid off and
sorry you guys are how old all the
numbers but it helps with the retirement
and everything taking it out I'm sorry
I'm 54. and my husband is 57. okay so
you guys are yeah enter
our home is paid off and I mean your net
worth your overall picture Audrey you
guys can't afford this you I mean you
can is what I'm saying I just want you
guys to be able to start to to save and
do what you can in the next year to be
able to not only just cash flow this 130
but gosh I would almost pay off this
other apartment first I don't think they
can cash flow it if I heard you right
Audrey you're not going to be able to
cash flow this out of country condo
I know but when he turns 15 oh yeah I'm
selling I'm sorry which one condo a or
condo B uh I'm gonna try to get out of
condo B I think condo I think you guys
don't have other options I know that's
my other thing so if they can't get
their money back I'm selling condo a and
I'm going to pay off condo B like this
I would Audrey because in the next four
years you guys may even switch locations
of where you want to be considering it's
an out of the country destination so if
you can't get out of it sell the first
condo your daughter can rent somewhere
else put attack that I mean that's going
to come up with most of the 130 you're
gonna owe and you guys hustle to pay
that off you do not want to be in debt
for that thanks for the call this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
folks you know that sinking feeling when
you make an offer on a house you love
and then you hear there's another offer
you need the Churchill Mortgage home
buyer Edge super fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Rachel Cruz we're
here to help you win in your money your
work and in your relationships so that
you live the life that you want to live
there's Peace and Freedom uh when you
are in control of those decisions and
you can be so excited to have you with
us triple eight eight two five five two
two five is the number
888-825-5225 okay Rachel I've got a fun
treat for you here
um I don't know if you I I I love the
the realtor.com the zillows oh yeah I
always like looking at the local real
estate market largely because I want to
see what the trends are doing and like
yeah you know and I get a little house
itch every once in a while I don't act
on it
I'm known to get a little house itch and
uh you know some people look at cars all
the time I'm looking in houses all the
time and so this story got my attention
and I thought it would be fun for
audience now for our podcast listing
audience the radio and all that you need
to go to YouTube
uh a little bit later this afternoon or
later this week if you want to see this
segment because we've got some pictures
this is a visual segment and so I've got
an article here in my hands
and uh the headline is Zillow gone wild
I love doing that sound James hates it
that's partly why I do it Zillow gone
wild broker make Jared Hewitt's Oklahoma
City home listing viral
uh so yeah go ahead
it's Jared here I don't know okay good
just making sure he's not like well no I
do know who he is oh he's the owner of
this home
that's who he is but I don't know
anything make sure we're all on the same
page is he anything other than the owner
of this home is do we know
um don't we don't know okay great okay
good just double check but I love that
you asked that
voice over actor really worked for
Disney Channel okay okay
well well done he's done well he's done
well so uh this this is this has gone
viral and and it's I guess it's a uh it
was posted on uh uh Zillow gone wild
okay and uh that's a sight I guess and
it featured this home okay it's got five
bedrooms five baths and magic in every
room I don't know who wrote that but
that's kind of interesting uh I got
questions it's listed for 1 million five
hundred ninety three thousand dollars or
Rachel two million four hundred fifty
thousand dollars if you keep the
Furnishings so close to another million
with the Furnishings absolutely so
anyway this this realtor says we know
how many how how big it is uh I don't
see square foot oh I see down here it's
yeah forty eight hundred forty eight
hundred square feet almost five thousand
yeah all right so there you go all right
so can we show the pictures guys here we
go now that wow now that looks like the
dining room to me and there we go so
unfortunate I will tell you that I'm
immediately feeling dizzy I know I have
a hint of dizziness look at that living
room and can we just talk about the
filter on these pictures that really
brings out the primary colors Ken oh see
I needed someone of your ilk to explain
that to me I would have thought that's
what it looks like you're saying that's
a filter no no it probably looks like it
but you can tell it's it's it's a
exaggerated we'll talk about this right
quick I want to talk about the zebra
print around the mirror and then we
looks like we've got some type of a
horse so this guy was a Disney Rider so
this is clearly the home of someone who
is very very creative but what's
interesting the contrast there is the uh
giant elk horns or whatever those were
with the zebra print so I don't know if
this is a hunter we're mixing or if
we've got an animal it's not good it
looks like a unicorn unfortunate we got
some uh what do you call those skinny
pyramids I don't even know Ken but who's
gonna pay another million dollars for
that stuff well see now there's sorry
Jared I'm with you I'm glad you said I
bet you're a wonderful I don't want any
of that furniture don't agree with the
style that's your style Jared it's too
much you do you Jared and we'll see if
someone pays an extra million bucks for
all this and an Oklahoma City too that's
the thing like you put it in LA or
something I'm like maybe yeah that's
what happened I feel like Jared and his
well Jared can't yeah he did he came
from L.A he came from Southern
California he did to Oklahoma City to
save on taxes I bet we could paint
Jared's whole story he's a Disney
writers he thought you know what I've
got family in Oklahoma City
his mom's there wanted to come back
creative place and then he goes wait a
second I got I got unicorns I got print
I got all kinds of crystals and a lot of
movement in that house it made me a
little bit dizzy and then I think he
said but I'm in Oklahoma City so I need
some elk horns as a chandelier I think
that's what happened now anyway this has
gone viral because of how magical
supposedly it is so here's some of the
comments all right
um people love it or hate it as you
might suspect
um look it looks like it could oh wait
I'm Gonna Save that one sorry the only
place I could possibly relax is the pool
I felt the same thing yep visually I was
tired it's a lot of a lot of brain
calories here's another person that's in
my Camp my eyes hurt and may never be
the same after that one it's so
obnoxious
tell if I just had a full-blown anxiety
attack or if it cured my anxiety that's
interesting and then my personal
favorite it looks like it could double
as Willy Wonka's opium den
wow so here's Willy Wonka on the opiums
it was a little strange because here's
the thing about your primary home unless
you have like there is a point not
ending amounts of money that you can
just do truly whatever you want and
you're not having to worry about any
effects of right any result of your
choices when it comes to your home uh
just know any property that you buy that
is unique and weird it's because it's
Unique and weird and the resell on that
the resale on that the the people that
are going to be interested in that your
funnel just went so slim oh to be able
yeah to resell something like that and
now this hopefully it didn't look like
weird architecture it's just weird Decor
we didn't see all we saw was the inside
of the house yeah so maybe it's not a
strange home maybe when you walk inside
somebody is the only place they would be
able to relax is the pool so apparently
the outside the pool is normal looks
normal yeah but just know when you go
and purchase a home you guys if it's oh
there's symmetrical yes it's great
visually wonderful but when you go and
purchase a home you know can people
think like oh yeah there's like this
really cool like unique thing here or
there or the way it's laid like if it's
if it's weird just it's a red flag and
again if you not worry about resell at
all and you can just go right in and do
you and that's what you want like go for
it I don't think you sell that house and
unless you remodel it I really don't how
many people on the planet want to live
in that house
well if you have a vision for if you can
walk in and like can you have a vision
no it's like looking at a kaleidoscope
you remember those when you were a kid
for those of you who are listening via
podcast on radio this house looks like a
kaleidoscope and here's another tip when
you're selling you want to you want it
to be bare you you truly want visually
it could be where someone can picture
themselves in the home right
101 that's just real estate 101 yeah and
they've done the opposite they've filled
every ounce of every wall and
everything it looks like one of those
Magic Eye pictures from the 90s it does
you're the what Magic Eye where you have
to stare at the weird pattern yeah like
look how many things can you find in the
picture close your eyes and you see how
do you see Jesus like in the dots yeah
yeah oh wow okay and uh then for a cool
see what I'm talking about for a cool
1.1 million more you get the crystal
horse and all the other
weird looking triangles I don't know
what else to call those I don't know
pyramids let's just learn from old
Jared's yeah Life Choices of course
Jared may be laughing all the way to the
bank yeah somebody rolls in 2.4 million
and said I'll take it all please I mean
wow it can't be good for the brain to
walk into that house do you know what I
mean like wow I mean where are you
stressful well but the pool area was
very nice very very nice maybe they're
going to work on the pool next when you
guys moved did y'all look at any homes
that you were like weird layout strange
nothing that I would call uh would that
would make it into the weird category
but certainly uh not efficient like
that's really like why would you do that
and and see that's the other thing if
you build a custom home you may have
some preferences but you got to think
about it this is really kind of out of
the ordinary it could affect you
absolutely there's people walking and go
this makes zero sense yes but it did for
this one person one time you guys just
built a house how stressful was that
making decisions years ago
I mean but we're pretty simple I mean I
would say you kept it simple to where
you go and you're in a great
neighborhood yeah you didn't stress
about a lot of those decisions no no it
was pretty
uh textbook I would say yeah I wouldn't
know because you haven't invited me over
you've been to our house not the new one
what I'm just gonna leave that what
happened to your new one either Ken all
right yes you have now we're there for
the Christmas party oh shoot with the
personality glad to know it was
memorable work party
to your work party work friends
oh folks we actually do like each other
there's more show coming up
thank you
[Music]
welcome back America you are joining the
conversation about your life your money
your work your relationships here on the
Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman Rachel Cruz
joins me and uh we were having fun last
segment talking about this uh this
Zillow gone wild house and uh the real
point of of featuring that Rachel is
because you got to be smart with with
such an expensive investment like your
house and we want to make sure that
you're thinking through if you're going
to resell if you buy and you had to move
what is what is needing to be considered
here when you make a purchase like this
and that's why we recommend that you
work with our our trusted trusted Ramsey
real estate uh Pros these these folks
are really uh experienced they're
skilled they know their market and what
does that do for you
it makes sure that you can navigate
things like higher interest rates uh
buying a new home and a new part of the
country you've got to have that trusted
real estate agent to make sure that
you're making a good decision so if
you're ready to buy don't let interest
rates hold you back you can find the
right home for you and your family team
up with a top agent who will help you
navigate the local market by going to
ramseysolutions.com agent that's
ramseysolutions.com slash agent Jackson
joins us now in Columbia South Carolina
Jackson how can we help
hello how are you guys we're having a
blast what's going on
um thanks for having me on um I just had
a I just have a personal and financial
situation I wanted to get some maybe
some advice or guidance from you guys
okay let you guys know what you're
talking about all right go for it um so
I recently opened a business
um early January of this year
um so I'm pretty new to it I think about
six months uh but I've just been kind of
looking at the numbers
um and it doesn't seem obviously I never
store early in the business but I can
just already tell
um early on that it's probably not going
to be a long-term solution for me what
is the business
um so I'm in a mattress store okay did
you buy it like did you buy it or did
you started I'm in a franchise
um most of the initial expenses I paid
for out of pocket okay I did take out a
business loan for 15 grand I know it's
that that loan's now down to about 10
grand
um I'm probably looking to get out of
the business as soon as I can just
because I don't want to waste time
um if I don't feel like it's gonna work
out I definitely don't want to keep
digging myself into a hole
um
I I just wanted some advice as far as so
I have currently I have about 11 Grand
and student loan debt
um that plus the the business loans my
total I don't have any any credit card
expenses or anything like that good
um I I I'm about 95 know my college
degree so I was just wondering if it
would be a wise decision to finish
school and get my degree um probably
over the second half of this year
um so by the time my my lease ends on my
building if um
by the time my lease ends I have I'd
have a degree but that would probably
put me in another five six grand debt as
far as student loans go or if it'll be a
better decision to hold off on their
degree and kind of tackle my debt
um and like a job without the degree
um before I kind of move forward yeah I
I at this point uh you're 95 percent
done with school so I would finish
school but I absolutely would press
pause because again it's going to be
there and you only have five percent to
go I don't want you going into any
further debt because right now in the
grand scheme of things to only have
eleven thousand dollars in student loan
debt my friend you're in really good
shape so many people in this country are
just absolutely buried in student loan
debt so this is very very doable to get
out quickly with your earning potential
um and I want you to get out of the the
uh the business loan as well when you
say get out of that what's that going to
look like is that selling your franchise
to someone else
um so I know it's a new location I've
built it up pretty well um I definitely
have some like some some my sales trend
is it's been pretty consistent I'm
sitting around like 10 grand a month
with about 50 gross profit margin so I'm
pretty much pulling in probably about
1500 to 2500 a month after I pay
everything okay
um I don't see like a path for it to
kind of exponentially take off works and
they're doubling or tripling that
um so as far as getting out that kind of
I kind of just want to be done with this
by the time I understand what I'm asking
is I'm not I'm not privy to the
franchise that you bought into so I'm
asking how do you exit do you have to
sell that franchise to someone else
or do you just say I'm shutting down
close doors so you'll close doors okay
so you're clearing you said 1500 a month
roughly 1500 to 2 000 a month I heard
um yes sir all right and are you needing
to live off of that or is that just the
business itself is spitting off that
much profit after all my expenses
um that's how much the business is
spitting off and then I'm also using
that kind of to live off of as well oh
okay well
um how many hours are you putting into
this business yourself
um I'm probably I'm probably spending
about like uh 50 60 hours a week here
um I definitely think I'm gonna have to
get a part-time job
um to kind of help you know support
myself for the for the least yeah all
right well the reason I ask you all this
stuff is because
if you didn't need you're you're putting
in too many hours 50 to 60 hours a week
you don't have a whole lot of margin
left although you can bust it
um if it were me I'd probably shut it
down now and uh and I would just attack
uh the loan just like I would I'd put it
in your personal snowball we teach a
debt snowball uh it's baby step two and
so we go smallest to largest so as I'm
looking at the numbers 10K on the
mattress store and 11k and student loan
and I'm gonna actually go ahead and cut
my losses now you're not there's if
they're there's you could be spending
those those 60s 50 to 60 hours somewhere
else right making good money double
maybe even triple that so how old are
you Jackson
I'm 24. 24 okay
um yeah that what's your degree in
or I know you haven't I know you don't
technically get it because you still
have my degree is in public health
um
I probably wouldn't choose the degree
again I have much respect for everyone
who's in the any any kind of Health Care
um career I just know probably wasn't
the smartest choice but I was young and
how much more money to finish that
okay what no how much more money to
finish this five percent that's left on
this degree
um it'll probably about five six grand
yeah
and I'm not Ken you may disagree with me
on this we'll see we'll see Jackson if I
were you yeah I would just go get any
job that I possibly could I would be
working extra I mean I would do anything
just because the amount of hours that
you're working again you could be
bringing in double this you could have
this debt knocked out
in a year I mean if you're making 56
weeks
so like go ahead and just clear all this
work in a job that's not your favorite
maybe not even in the line of work but
it's but it's paying your bills to get
you through school and by the time
you're 28 Jackson you'll have a degree
you'll have no debts and you'll be able
then to make career choices
that you actually want to make but if I
were you I would just go find any job I
could and I'd be working extra are you
single
I am yeah so I mean I would be working
nights I mean anything Jackson because
once you clean all this up and once you
save up that money to get that degree uh
and you'll be working while you're in
school too you know you're still so
young which is so encouraging that you
could still be in your mid to late 20s
to find the career path that you want I
completely agree and here's why I think
you need this time to figure out what
path you want to take now you may know
what path you want to take we're we're
about a minute and a half from a break
so I can't dig into that piece I'm going
to give you some free tools though but
Rachel's right if you get a 20 an hour
job that's what I'm I mean that's what
you're aiming for minimum 20 an hour
that's that's just for four taxes that's
a thousand bucks a week if working 50
hours You're Gonna Knock this debt out
in about five six months if you really
get after it and now that we've got a
game changer now we get to cash flow uh
to finish the degree if you really want
to finish it it gives you that college
degree you don't have to go into that
field you're so close I'd go ahead and
do it I'm not a fan of college degrees
that we're not going to use however it
won't hurt you I'd go ahead and finish
and I would be thinking about what is it
that I want to do with my life you've
got an entrepreneurial spirit I can hear
that and I think you got to come up with
the next idea and if you got to work in
the field for a while to learn the ins
and outs and then decide to step out
cash cash from here on out and I think
you're going to get out of this thing
relatively pain-free but Rachel's
absolutely right let's just go get a
good paying job crush the debt come up
with the five to six grand to finish the
degree and then let's just move forward
in life hang on the line Austin let's
get him uh the assessment the get clear
assessment help him get some ideas for
his future and then the book from
paycheck to purpose it's the map to get
there uh you're gonna be fine Jackson
but get rid of this debt with Reckless
abandon
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Coleman Rachel Cruz joins me Triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number our scripture of the day
comes from Romans 15 13 May the god of
Hope fill you with all joy and peace in
believing so that by the power of the
Holy Spirit you may abound in hope our
of course our quote from from Rachel's
friend did you see this what no Candace
Cameron Bureau is that how you say that
I love her uh excuse me all of a sudden
I'm getting choked up don't know why he
has given us life and we can either live
that life with joy believing that we can
make a difference or we can wallow in
sorrow believing we can't how about that
from your friend Candace you'll have to
text her and tell her we read a quote of
hers today came up on the show there you
go uh how many of you know that you need
to save money but at the end of the
month there doesn't seem to be enough
money to save we get it but we've got
some good news this week we're breaking
down 27 simple tips for tweaking your
budget that can make a huge impact and
help you find extra money to save sign
up at ramseysolutions.com
newsletter to subscribe to our Sunday
newsletter and get on the fast track to
saving money in no time Misty is up in
Mayfield Kentucky Misty from Mayfield
how can we help
um well I've got a question about my
daughter's uh continuing education all
right she
um just graduated from college we cash
flowed her through her undergrad now she
has been accepted into vet school and
will be starting vet school in the fall
which comes with a much much bigger
price tags
wondering we have a good retirement
um and was wondering about taking money
from the retirement no tuition no please
I beg of you no please the other choice
is getting loans
well that's not the first of all that's
a false choice but before we get to the
choice
I'm begging you do you understand why
I'm begging you not to pull from your
retirement how old are you Nancy how old
are you okay I mean my husband is 65. oh
we could pull from his without any
penalties and how much do you guys have
in your retirement so yeah we have about
950 000. 950 000.
uh-huh
how much is the school
the school is 22 000 a semester a
semester how many total semesters does
she have to take it'll be eight she'll
be four years
yeah I mean she'll be a doctor when she
comes out of this she'll be a doctor of
veterinary medicine yeah and she'll also
resent taking care of animals because
she won't be able to focus on taking
care of those precious little furry
fellows uh because she's miserable with
debt I'm just I'm just keeping it real
and let me ask you this is this a uh is
this the champagne uh the wine or the
beer veterinarian school this is more
the beer this is not the most expensive
wow not at all okay well she's got so
what did you what has she done to this
point from a school standpoint because
this is you said continuing education is
she just going straight out genuine
she's already done her undergrad
and has been accepted into vet school so
this is the what was her Underground
it was in biomedical
pre-emphasis on pre-vet all right can I
ask a silly question it may not even be
silly it might be though
can she get a good paying job in that
field that is not Veterinary level or
even if it's not even animal related but
with that degree can she get a really
good paying job to where if she's
disciplined she can save up the money
and pay cash for this and you guys get
to retire
with all that money that you've been
working so hard to save is that possible
I mean yes you can get a job as
something else right but being able to
get back into vet school would probably
be a no why
because she's turned it down she got
accepted her first try which does not
happen very often on vet school it is
hard it's harder to get into vet school
than it is medical school
just because there's not that many so
okay so okay so Mitzi can I tell you
what I'm hearing
there's a level to your questioning and
the way you're framing some of this
that's that that are these extremes no
one ever gets in it's it's big and it's
like these are the only two choices this
is the only choice like it just feels
really big and what I have found Mitzi
is that when life when I feel like I
only have one option or two options in
life and I gotta do either one and both
of them are not great but oh my gosh
it's the only things I have you end up
making really bad decisions versus
pausing and saying hey what's option C
which option what what is option d n e
when you pin yourself in a corner you
find yourself that you're gonna make a
possibly a very poor decision if both
options are not great and what you've
presented on the call are both not great
options I mean pulling from your
retirement I think is unnecessary
um even though you could do it without
penalty but I want you guys Mitzi to be
able to have a fantastic retirement
without taking out close to two hundred
thousand dollars uh to pay for this
that's not an option for me Misty I
listen well and I'm still I'm still
um working and yeah and I think about
what she can work she can work she can
pay her way through this and you know
it's so many of these programs
um they have you know places where you
work for the college can and you're able
to you know that they help with a degree
you go and you find maybe a veterinarian
that you work under and you know you
promise like hey I'll be here for five
years if you help pay for school I mean
like there are there are options and I
know they're slim and I know that it
doesn't happen for everyone but I would
do I would I would overturn I would turn
over every single rock that is a
possibility to help with this price tag
because it's just it's a lot and when
you don't have the money and she's what
21 22 years old she's 22. yeah she's
making a decision that man it's gonna be
with her for a really long time and we
just will never
be on the side of encouraging debt and
even student loans and all the things so
I think she can work her way through it
I think I think there's two things I'm
going to challenge you with number one
she can she can work through vet school
and and she can find a way
um she can get back in if she turns it
down I don't buy for a second that
she'll never be able to get back in I
don't buy that by the way nobody cares
well I know you don't know but I'm just
telling you I don't buy it and so I can
still hear someone who's looking for an
excuse to pull out retirement money or
you pay her way through this and if
that's what you want to do we can't stop
you and it's your decision but I would
beg you not to pull from your retirement
uh and I would beg you to come up with
any other way even if you gotta help and
you want to help fine that's cool but
she needs to have some skin in the game
in this or else she's going to get out
of that school and she's going to be
under a mountain of debt Mitzi how much
money do you make a year because your
husband tired so how much income do you
guys bring in
um well he's together with his actually
he's on disability okay retirement
um with his in mind probably I'm gonna
say about a hundred and ten thousand
a year
yeah okay and what what Financial shape
are you guys in do you what do you owe
on your house and other other debts we
lost our house in the tornado that came
through Mayfield oh I'm sorry
oh my God but we had very good insurance
so we are currently rebuilding our house
right now okay
um
so but other than that
that's it okay and how much will you owe
will you owe anything on that house or
will insurance
cover the bill I'm sure it should cover
all of it okay that's great unless uh
except for you know there's been a few
upgrades that I've done because I'm like
this is our house that will be in
forever and some of the things that I
really hated about the other house and
we're not going to do this time sure
you're right Misty I'm jumping in real
quick because I want to give you some
hard facts here we're running running
out of time you're looking at 3 666
bucks a month if this is just a straight
22 per semester it usually never is but
let's say it's 44 a year that's what
you're looking at and so if you're going
to cash flow this if you're going to
help and she's going to help these are
the real numbers and it just helps
sometimes to look at this and go can we
do this without debt and we're gonna
have to do 366 bucks a month
do you understand what I'm saying that's
that's the challenge before you if that
can be done
and she can help a big chunk of that and
you don't pull from your retirement she
doesn't go in debt then go for it uh but
but but please as Rachel said don't
choose the worst of some false choices
and uh we appreciate the call you're a
great mom you got a great heart and your
daughter's gonna I'm sorry about the
house yeah sorry about your loss oh
tough stuff Rachel Cruz good hour thank
you for being with me my friend James
Childs and our fearless crew for keeping
us on the air in you America for
listening this is your show this is the
Ramsey Show
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsey Baby
Steps go to ramsesolutions.com and click
on the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]